how did we get here what are you seeing
behind those closed doors that we don't
see there's a reason why physicians
commit suicide it's just not what we're
trying to talk about what needs to be
fixed give the antibiotic give the
percocet give the xanax what chance that
our kids have that's what primary care
is in the united states mission
impossible so why is this message not
out there there's money why do we
prescribe more oxycodone in this country
than any other country in the world i'm
an addictive personality so it's either
all in
or nothing so i love my patients but i
can't do everything that's just pure
crack cocaine for kids it's cost
effective and there's fewer side effects
and it's cheap and it's available to
everyone if people don't know they
should know
beautiful day
good morning guys here with anthony cave
he's an anesthesiologist here in the san
francisco bay area and you're also a
integrative medicine specialist
integrative medicine medical specialist
so today guys we're going to talk about
the medical world and there i've seemed
to find there's a big gap between us
citizens
and what's going on behind the closed
doors in hospitals so we're going to
talk about
let's say some of the disconnect some of
the challenges some of the things that
aren't going so well at the moment i
can't think of anything brave anthony's
here with us to do so
but it's not all doom and gloom we're
going to talk about
some of the ways all of us
you me anthony it seems i haven't
figured out so far but how we can
implement things in our lives to make
them much better during these coveted
times and just
life in general
so anthony what's the biggest
problem you're seeing right now that's a
wide question but uh
what what what are you seeing behind
those closed doors that we don't see and
as an anesthesiologist you're seeing
people
on the line of life and death right
every day
every day we see people right on the
line
and yet our society has been looking a
lot
like a pennywise pound foolish kind of
story okay
what do you mean by that
so imagine trying to save
a couple pennies here and there but then
in the long run losing pounds and pounds
and pounds are uh
we look at for example masks right now
right we recognize there's a very real
benefit to masks in the correct
situation and we recognize that the risk
of transmission situations can be very
low
we focus on
the things that
might save pennies like
masks in outdoor settings where the risk
for transmission is low
but we're unfortunately very mute about
the pound okay about what are the
underlying risk factors that increase
the risk for severe
covet infection for example okay
so why do you think there's no attention
on these overall factors these you know
there's sort of some big themes here but
like overall health and society is going
to better society
right why is there a lack of attention
on that
a healthy society is good for you it's
good for me it's good for every single
person because we're all invested in the
health care system if someone can't pay
for it you and i have to pay for it at
the end of the day right and money's a
finite resource people forget if
somebody is using too much of it
unfortunately that might mean less for
somebody else what are you seeing
anthony when people are on that line
you know
between death life and death you're that
guy holding them there
which has got to have a lot of stress
and obviously responsibility
what are you seeing in the health of
society or what can we learn from that
i'll let you take that one how did we
get here
how did we get here how did we get here
something that people need to recognize
is that
in the operating room in the emergency
room in acute medical settings we do a
phenomenal job with western medicine
okay we save lives when you get hit by a
car on the highway if you're unfortunate
to have a gunshot wound do you have a
bad accident right will do the best job
with our cutting edge medical devices
and all those things undoubtedly sure
but this is
the minority of what costs us as society
as a society and what causes us as a
medical care system
the heartache essentially we see the
sick people out there and it's rarely
from these types of acute conditions
it's usually from the consequences of
high blood pressure
from
poor nutrition from obesity from
diabetes when people get their
amputations from their diabetes when
they don't have eyesight from their
diabetes when their kidneys fail this is
what constitutes
a lot of what we see
and when they end up on the or table
because they need their limb amputated
or they have an aortic aneurysm because
they've been smoking their whole life
how did we get here
what happened for the years and decades
we had to intervene to help prevent this
from happening
it breaks my heart
hot dogs in schools aren't helping
well i mean maybe the doritos help
sometimes i don't know but i don't know
if i can say brand names like that but
yeah the vending machines to the kids
the targeted advertising of unhealthy
habits to our children right does not
help
so what do what do you think you're in
you're in the medical world the the
reason these things are not being talked
about at a
you know there's not a lot of volume on
this topic
it's because where's the money to be
made it's not on prevention i'm gonna
throw you under the bus a little oh say
whatever you want obviously but it's not
prevention right
yeah unfortunately an ounce of
prevention is
a pound of treatment
but
we're disincentivized it's the plain
unfortunate truth and if people don't
know they should know you're just son of
a disincentivized as as a medical worker
as a as a hospital but
well
pharmaceutical company
dude you're typically famous
now you are awesome
yay thank you for the great work you're
doing thank you you're you're a very
health conscious individual
i can tell i am i am i'm jealous of you
i want to be doing what you're doing do
it grab a girl go grab a gopro
anything we do there's always a risk and
benefit anytime someone's having surgery
for example yes you might take out the
appendix and they might be just fine
they probably will be fine but they
could also die in the operating table
from complications of anesthesia they
could die from affection right can i
tell you one of one of the experiences i
had
in in the medical world before and i've
been
to the doctors very very few times i've
had very few injuries luckily
so i was on a mountain i i was mountain
biking
crashed the bike broke my finger
got splinted up healed up fine a few
weeks later i was getting this tingling
like this tingling down my arm when i
was sleeping
and so i went to the doctor and
i said doc i'm getting some of this
tingling is there anything i can do
and he and he did this
do you mind go for it he's like
see peter what we can do is what we'll
do is we'll just take out this top rib
here so we remove this it will it will
free i forget how he said it but like
the nerves will become unpinched blah
blah blah we just gotta we just gotta
remove that part yeah and i felt like i
was talking to an auto mechanic about my
suspension not working and i said doc is
there what about what about yoga or
acupuncture is there anything else i
could do i'd rather not start
dismantling my body over some tingling
at night yeah and he's like you're sure
me no
that won't work not gonna happen
and
i didn't follow his advice thank god two
weeks i have all your ribs in place i
still have all my ribs two weeks later
it went away it went away and i'm i
haven't felt it since we call this the
tincture of time in medicine
tincture of time god it's got a saying
oh of course because this this is what
you just said
if things are on a spectrum
and the body has an incredible potential
to heal itself undoubtedly
nobody makes money when the body heals
itself we need to face it so
he's making a sale
uh i don't want to be careful i wasn't
there i don't want to speak for the
surgeon i wasn't i don't know what your
symptoms were
but
traditionally the truth is that when we
go to medical school in the united
states
we are trained to deal with acute
situations which we do very very well
right right we are not trained for
wellness we're not trained for health
optimization we are typically not
trained for
low risk interventions so who is trained
for that and who is you know
you know giving us that information in
society it's not the cdc right we're not
having our big organizations telling us
how to live i mean i'm sure there's
stuff on their websites but
i don't feel like there's some
especially this year you think there
would be like
okay
the best thing you can do for yourself
is getting a really good health
i've failed on that a little bit this
year i've doubled down on my chocolate
intake a double down go for the
i'm not a purist like you it's not
there's not as much dopamine in it
because
because let's face it shift food
gives you a rush right but did you know
that you can retrain your body did you
know that the dopamine rush can be
trained
no no we don't talk about it
over here let's check this out
the pallet the pallet adjusts
the pallet adjusts
i don't know that's that's a big that's
a big sale anthony how does my palette
adjust
because because sugar is the dopamine
it's the quick hit it is but there's
more than just sugar that can do it but
see that once again there's no what
incentive does anyone have to try to
explain to you how your lifestyle can
fundamentally change your physiology
it's just not what we're trying to talk
about because
and it's and it's not the fault of
doctors we have 15 minutes maybe with a
patient maybe 20 30 minutes for a first
time encounter you guys are pressured
hard these days right we are pressured
hard it's not a sob story it's the
reality right right we have very limited
timing because you do you want to be
late for your appointment yeah no i mean
sorry you don't want the doctor to be
late to see you right right right well
then if
you can't take extra time with your
doctor and have the next patient be late
right i mean it wouldn't be fair so we
need to be on a timetable yep to keep
everyone happy it's really mission
impossible that's what primary care is
in the united states mission impossible
they ask way too much from primary care
docs
and there's no way they can deliver
who's going to sit down with you for an
hour to talk about how your body can
heal itself
who is going to sit down and do that
right who we're not trained we don't
make money because we don't get
compensated
as much for preventive things as we do
for acute fixes okay and i'm not going
to comment on the right or wrong insofar
as to say that you can tell me if you
would rather have somebody spend an hour
talking with you about your lifestyle
right and how you can prevent it
versus being on the or table 20 years
later because your coronary arteries are
filled with junk from the lifestyle that
led up to that okay what percentage of
your patients
are there because of bad choices in life
recognizing that we don't have the
absolute truth number yeah it's probably
going to be well over 50 probably in the
75 percent okay
okay but it depends on many factors and
i got to say this to be complete here
they're going to be some cancer centers
that look at only specialty care and
pediatrics the child with the
glioblastoma in the brain it's very
difficult to say yeah
yeah sure the child has got a tumor in
their eyeball difficult to say that it
was a lifestyle choice yeah versus
the
older woman with uterine cancer
with risk factors that we know revolve
from elevated bmi and obesity gotcha so
what do you want people to know you you
reached out you said
there's sort of an information gap these
days
in your industry i hate to call it an
industry but that's what it's called
right well it's an industry okay there's
an information gap between the public
and your industry
i mean in a nutshell these are all like
five hour long conversations we could
have every one of these topics
but what is
what needs to be fixed in this sense
like what would be some
some remedy
quick fixes i hate to say that i don't
want to say band-aids we need deep dives
right we need to die structural deep
dives but it starts
yes at the organizational level in terms
of community structure and public health
of course this is going to be the
bedrock
it's unequivocal how important this is
but right there is also personal
responsibility and agency and this is
the beauty the elegance of the human
body
it can heal itself with the right
empowerment
and
to answer your question of what is the
single most important thing is patient
empowerment everybody
can
heal themselves to an extent
but
their environment may not enable them to
do so which is why it's a two
pronged approach of course the community
and the environment has to be optimized
but we can never forget that the patient
themselves has incredible potential
to heal their body
how is that
how is that approached now it's approach
that the patient doesn't have incredible
control over their destiny or or what do
you think on that no absolutely you're
correct because
the message is that you you see
commercials for antidepressant
medications for erectile dysfunction
medications instead of addressing
the underlying cause what we forget is
that all these drugs that are pushed out
there have side effects this is why what
i said earlier in
western medical approaches we
unfortunately
forget
the risk benefit of every recommendation
we make okay everything as benign as any
medication may have potential tremendous
potential for benefit but also has
potential
for problems right
and
this is the opposite of patient
empowerment where we look at lifestyle
where you
nearly
unanimously have tremendous potential
for benefit without the side effects
and with less cost when we look at 20 of
gdp going to health care costs
the lifestyle modification components
don't contribute to the 20 percent
number that we're talking about right
right
oh let's go up here
here we are in golden gate park guys
such a beautiful park in san francisco
okay so
there's a lot we can do on an individual
level but it's hard i'm not in my
optimum shape right now i've been in
much better shape before why do you stay
in prison when the doors are wide open
we know a lot of
uh i don't know how no it's good how
how how do you do it you it's nice it
sounds good anthony like i am empowered
but i'm also empowered right now i have
a craving to go get that you know that
cookie after this talk
right so
you're empowered yes okay
but give me a little more on that
like you're a strong you're a
strong-willed guy yeah and you're seeing
it i guess you have an advantage too
you're seeing every day at work
the fallout from bad habits
we all are but yeah yeah no you more so
yeah but people anybody who's sending a
check to the irs
who knows that they're taxed yeah but
there's a disconnect there's a
disconnect like you're not connected
you're not upset
you're in those hospitals
you're seeing people dealing with type 2
diabetes which you just scared me about
because that comes from eating too much
sugar right
multifactorial but yes lifestyle and
refined sugars yeah
are one of the strong contributors we
believe to developing and particularly
in children and when children develop
type 2 diabetes it's the worst case
scenario for us all yeah
because they have a little life ahead of
them they're on the system their whole
life in the health care system and their
whole and not to mention their own
personal life laws it breaks my heart i
was telling you the other day i had a
patient in the operating room uh-huh 12
years old let's go down here i weighed
over 200 pounds
12 12 years old 200 pounds over 200
pounds and
uh
so what's his what's his chances in life
well there's there's unfortunately a
trajectory that is not fixed but is
likely it's all about probabilities okay
and unfortunately when that happens that
that patient still has the potential to
turn things around the human body can
recover
but it takes all the more
willpower
and acceptance of responsibility
okay so
is it fair to say
that
elements of the system look at that as a
perfect patient because there's a lot of
money that's going to be spent on his
life throughout his life if he doesn't
change you know it's funny you say it
that way because
it's
in some ways
money to be
gained from the
treatment that comes from
long-term
insulin from
antidiabetic medications that one may
take but it's also moral injury to the
healthcare system because
we're human beings as doctors it breaks
our heart it hurts we don't want to see
that child sick we don't want to see
their parents sick right but what tools
do we have when we're constrained in a
system or we have 15 minutes with the
child and their parent
to talk about the lifestyle
modifications you ask what do we do well
it starts with education empowerment
starts with education and awareness but
it's difficult to give these tools to
patients when the
cards are stacked against them
the cards are stacked against us all in
this type of
me okay one way to unpack i would say
okay
easy food choice is fast food that's an
easy example that's cards are stacked
against you
right and i was just in southern
california so commercial real estate
right we all think in california
commercial real estate or maybe across
the nation is in the gutter like
downtown san francisco for lease signs
everywhere right yeah commercial
properties
but i was talking to a commercial agent
down there i'm like
how's how's the industry thinking the
answer was going to be terrible he said
oh my my work is great right now i'm
like whoa how how's that he's like fast
food restaurants
opening up left and right
because of the pandemic i guess right
because it's easy to go in and get
takeout and yet
and yet while masks have a role
the role
is pennies compared to the pounds
of
that type of lifestyle nudging people
right
right
so okay how about this anthony what what
the irony
everyone has a mask on here
outside as we're talking about pennies
and pounds with masks
what yeah what's your take on that
everyone has a choice to do what they
want okay i will respect their choice it
is
on consider it is inconsistent however
to place so much importance on a 0.01
risk
yeah versus a 1 risk and the 1 or 10
risks come from an accumulated
lifetime burden of fast food and
unhealthy lifestyle choices that far
overshadows the 0.01 percent
risk recognizing those are somewhat
arbitrary numbers but orders of
magnitude difference yep
versus what we saw and comparing what we
saw earlier to what most people are
subjecting their bodies to on a daily
basis um wearing a mask can be super it
is very important give us give us the
lowdown on that please
i have my theories here's how i operate
outside
if i'm not close to people there's
ventilation uv light from all the
doctors i've talked to outside that risk
is so low they told me don't wear a mask
around people up close and personal
inside definitely
i wear a mask
are you at liberty to say this or is
that too too controversial that's a very
reasonable approach i carry a mask with
me because i might run into yeah and i
have one with both of the masks on hand
yes
when we're looking at the 0.01 risk my
personal risk profile is that
i try to optimize everything but even i
i don't believe that 0.01 or you know
roughly with this if you want to
calculate it however you want an outdoor
setting is is very low
it is very low it is it is low it's
undeniably low yeah
and there is realistically more things
that are going to kill us than being in
an outdoor setting
not wearing a mask
recognizing that we have a mask with us
should the environment change because
hey
we might go into a cafe right now and
that's a different risk
so
what this leads to also is what you're
saying earlier is fear right and so
we're not
if we're in this constant state of like
on the heels instead of on the toes
worried
worried feeling in fear mode in panic
mode
that also
hurts overall well-being and health
right it's wristband it's hard to
measure that though it's really well yes
and no yes or no because like i was
saying earlier everything is a risk
benefit every decision we make in life
has a risk and a benefit the risks of
fear and a continual
state of concern and worry yeah is
actually not that difficult to quantify
we have heart rate variability
measurements
measurements there's so many ways of
quantifying the burden of persistence
unmitigated stress elevated cortisol
levels etc that have very negative
impacts okay and living in a state of
fear
particularly in childhood
can result in long-term
psychological and physical physiological
problems and i've seen it in many ways
like being in the hoods
you know there's this there's this uh
people are worried about safety and
they're always on edge you know when i
was in i did this video in miami in the
hoods of miami right the guys i was
really cool guys but when they got in
there because we're on miami beach they
were chill when we got in there it's
like their guard ramped up if you're too
relaxed it's actually a danger for
survival meaning you're an easier target
so you have to have that fear mode up
to exist which has to be unhealthy right
it's unequivocal this is not
controversial yeah that living in a
constant state of fear
not only hurts your psychological
well-being but very much your
physiological well-being undoubtedly
there's no question so why is this
message not out there
on on a like a on a macro level
at least in the us right now i don't i
don't see it i don't hear it
like
why is there not an overall well-being
approach you think there would be
because like we said an ounce of
prevention is a pound of treatment right
yet
we don't have that type of incentivized
public health structure looking at the
macro scale we don't incentivize these
things
and in your training in med school
so that the public health system doesn't
do it as well as it could it does a good
job in many ways and we're not
downplaying it right there's a good job
but there's much more there's always
room for improvement bashing always room
for improvement sure at the individual
doctor level
it's partly not our responsibility the
same way as it is a public health
message because we deal like i said we
deal with acute people we are trained to
save lives when someone collapses right
here we know how to do cpr defibrillate
then we save lives right in the moment
very well
when we go past that we drop off very
quickly in our cost effectiveness
of prevention and treatment we can do it
but not cost effectively because we have
15 minutes at a time what are you going
to do a patient lives there 99 of their
life at home
at their school their work whatever what
is 15 minutes in the office
realistically going to do other than
manage some medications try to talk
about smoking cessation trying to talk
about lifestyle and then go to the next
patient because we don't want to get a
bad yelp review if we're late to see
patients right right we're under so much
scrutiny what are we gonna do is it
getting harder in your industry suddenly
it's getting harder it's getting harder
for doctors what in the last five years
ten years it's been longer but well
you're young
you haven't been in it for 40 years we
unfortunately have social media that is
escalating and it's very difficult when
we're trying to do what is right from
our training from the decades we spend
in school running licensed yeah and then
having people with perhaps
less training and less education in our
field
trying to review us is a difficult
situation to put us in who's trying to
review you patience okay okay it's a
little bit it's a little bit challenging
to try
medicine is a little bit different than
a random industry because the customer
is always right it's a typical business
the patient might come and the common
example they want antibiotics they want
opioids for pain they want i want my
trim at all doc i need my percocet
criminal what's that trim it all what's
that um it's a synthetic opiate it's
kind of like um
it's a weak type of opioid if you will
okay so people who want to and this is
very real and this is these are the
struggles that we have
because we cannot give out opioids
liberally we have we're not being
epidemic because
pain was viewed as the fifth vital sign
uh many people will say because of
industry influence to help doctors be
more and concerned and more
receptive to prescribing opioids
for patients in pain and at a fear of
being negatively reviewed and it's easy
to if you're put if you have to keep a
volume of clients and you have to be on
time the easy out would be
here's the med give the antibiotic give
the percocet give the xanax and that's
that that's band-aid stuff right this is
all this is nearly always banded there
are always exceptions but by and large
we're talking about band-aid solutions
they're gonna you know as an example
they're gonna be patients with cancer
terminal yeah who yeah they might need
percocet they might in their last five
years of life the last six months left
yeah they might need okay oxycodone but
these are that stuff's terrible i took
that oh it is like i had like a like a
crazy dreams and it was it was like a it
was like on psychedelics or something
but not in a good way
and yet why do we prescribe more
oxycodone in this country than any other
country in the world
this is this is getting really
depressing so anthony bring bring this
ship around
give us
give us the hollywood ending no not the
hollywood ending but give us give us
something to go for or hope for let's go
up here this is a cool little trail
system look at how fit people are here
though you got to say
this is the way to go this is the way to
go it's a nice environment
people taking responsibility over their
own health
yeah
in the context of them having the
ability to do so an area where the
weather isn't amenable there is a park
there are sidewalks we're not worried
about crime we need to recognize we're
in an environment that facilitates this
system everything's set here for it a
lot of places don't have this yeah and
and we never want to blame blame games
are not how we do things in medicine but
empowering is what we need to do more of
okay so this is this is the solution
this is where we're gonna get out of
this thing this is one one of the
solutions okay so break it down for us
anthony empowering
other than making good conscious
sober decisions
which i'm even ha i'm having a hard time
with myself
seriously with the sweets that's my one
thing i don't drink i don't do any drugs
you know sweets
that's good for you ready but see you've
already you got to focus on the right
things how did you cut those things out
the drinking ayahuasca okay i don't know
if that's a pro i don't know if that's
a positive thing in your world but
it was a very powerful psychedelic that
brought me out of it
well then i think it's then it was worth
it there's a point there where you have
you've changed a lifelong
habit yes through one experience
that that's a very uh
it's hard to argue against that let's
put it that way yeah and i and i never
thought
i never thought i was an alcoholic
and until you stop completely
it was like there was always a
refrigerator humming in the background
like you know those old refrigerators
that always make that noise you don't
notice it most of the time but it's
always there and so every time i was at
the you know start of a vacation or the
end of a long day
to go to the beer and it was nice and it
was relaxing
and i'm not i'm not like looking down on
that or anyone that drinks it's not my
point but for me
removing it was like it opened like this
light this light came into my life
and by having a i'm an addictive
personality so it's either all in
or nothing
a lot of high questioning people are
like that
so by having nothing there's never a
choice it doesn't take up any mind space
i never have to think about it i don't
battle over it
that sort of thing
so
so you just have provided part of the
answer
how people feel when they're healthy
people have from childhood oftentimes
live the life unhealthy
and they believe that's the status quo
when they get a taste of
what a healthy life is like
it can be life-changing the example that
i like to use with patients is that
imagine a tennis ball that's soaked wet
it can't tell if a drop of water comes
on because it's already saturated with
water if you let the thing dry out they
have a dry tennis ball yup and now a
drop of water comes on it
then you can tell oh
there's something something's different
but people we live our lives in a state
of chronic stress chronic unhealthy
behaviors from diet lifestyle stress
from our environments all the other
issues we talked about it's more than
just the patient it's the environment
they live in
but
it's hard for them to see what as you
said the light
is like when you live your whole life in
this route even in your victoria
department inflammatory environment yes
yeah but one people realize what it's
like some not all but some will never
want to go back that was your experience
yeah it was personally my experience as
well
so
it's
the realistic
the realistic approach or the cold hard
truth is nobody can do it for you you
have to want to do it yourself is that
is that fair to say
that's part of the solution because i
mean kids can be educated obviously that
is one thing and they need good examples
but when you're an adult
you need to have the cards not stacked
against you as much as they are now and
our society makes it difficult
to
be healthy and to be responsible and to
accept responsibility for your health
why does it why does it make it
difficult there's money
you need to follow the money when it
comes to our health decisions we think
we're in control of our health and we
can be in control
but that's not the message that we are
given
when we are bombarded
from every angle by advertisements
trying to peddle right unhealthy
behaviors when people make a buck off of
our health
it's hard when people know what makes
our dopamine rush it's hard for us to
resist that and when we target our kids
for this what chance that our kids have
it's mission impossible like like i just
remember growing up with a
cartoon i mean uh commercials for
captain crunch oh and tricks cereals
right yeah i mean that's just pure crack
cocaine for kids there is nutrition it
is almost like smoking some will
consider it to be like smoking where
there is no benefit
right and only harm okay because the
nutritional value of all those things
you're talking about is nearly zero and
the harm is incredible and it's marketed
in a fun jovial
positive way it's all manipulative it's
all manipulative and but we're
manipulating the health
of our kids
this is the health of the future what
chance do we have and we're surprised
that our health care expenditures are
approaching 20
of gdp that number we can't understate
that number when we're talking about
stimulus checks and all these things
going on 1.9 trillion is a huge number
yet we spend so much
unfortunately on feudal medical care
every year
okay i was going to say there where's
the where's the good way out of this but
the whole system needs to change in some
way shape or form well you're saying the
the emergency care or the like the very
you know what's deemed as western style
of treatment is is nailed down pretty
rock solid here if i need brain surgery
this is the best place to be right yeah
fair to say very
preventative
not at all no no
and so how does that how does that turn
around it starts
by
educating and raising awareness and by
recognizing what cards are stacked
against us when people realize what
they're being fed through advertisements
and can start to look through the veil
that's trying to manipulate them they
get better insight into what
their tendencies are and how they're
being manipulated okay to begin to
counter those okay would you say other
doctors share the same frustrations
you know that you're talking about today
we are a normal thing
we're humans like you we have hearts we
don't want to see people suffering
absolutely but we're also
suffering from
a really challenging situation where the
end of the day we only have so much
candle we can burn before our wick goes
out yeah and there's a reason why
physicians commit suicide at the rates
they do it's a high rate it is i know
this physicians burn out they have moral
injury like anyone else if not more
because we are faced with this
incredible burden that we can't do as
much as we want about because like i
said we're limited to such short
encounters it takes a toll on us so you
must be pushed between the industry
that's basically the machine
and then the humanity
and when you're seeing that
yeah and then and
so when we talk about once a reporter
once told me they said doctor you can't
die from stress
right and i just i didn't even know how
to respond people die from stress all
the time
and
suicide is one of the most
overt signs of that but did you know
that you can go into heart failure from
physiologic stress you heard of broken
heart syndrome no yeah it's a very very
real phenomena that
we have we doctors have seen all the
time i've seen it my wife is an er
doctor has seen it when people have
strong emotional feelings their heart
can go into failure and they can die if
you want an even better example before
surgery what we see
um
classic classic example about how strong
what our thoughts are and how they
control the rest of our body when people
see blood like when an iv goes in yeah
you know people can faint to the side of
sight of blood yeah
that is your brain
reducing circulation to your
to the brain itself causing you to pass
out your brain is controlling your heart
your blood vessels causing you to pass
out that is how direct and how fast that
relationship is between what you're
thinking and the rest of your body
now these are examples of bad right
we're talking about people
fainting and losing consciousness and
having heart failure but you can do the
same thing as well
you can train your body
to
be healthier as well to reduce the
inflammatory burden this is where the
non-western approaches are so powerful
this is where we have tai chi and yoga
and acupuncture mindfulness-based stress
reduction right this is the good side
there's a way out of this there's
absolutely a way out of this and the
best part this is cool
the best part is why it's cost effective
and there's fewer side effects and it's
cheap and it's available to everyone
it's available to everyone you need to
go to the pharmacy to buy a chill pill
you know who loses out ah and i'm not
against capital i love capitalism and i
love investing but the shareholders lose
out of that equation if you don't count
the patience of the shareholders yes if
you count the patient as a shareholder
peter
they win
yes
true who so this is the question who is
the shareholder in your health and in my
health and everyone in this park's
health who is the shareholder
okay well it's also
other people an industry
that may not have the same incentives
that you and i have yeah yeah yeah and
we need to recognize that at the end of
the day we are the advocates for our
health so we need to bring that power
back it's cheesy as that sounds right we
need to bring that back to ourselves and
i hate to say this it's life and death
the end of the day
when patients die from
a lifelong burden of diabetes or
hypertension you know that person lost
their life and it might sound cheesy but
it's true it is a life-and-death
situation where we need to advocate for
our own health we need to be in charge
because if we're not in charge who else
is going to do it your docs they love
you you know i love my patients but i
can't do everything
we can i appreciate that truth
you can't i cannot export the
responsibility of my health to you you
have a wife that's in medical
uh give kids no yeah okay so you'll have
kids eventually i'm sure you'll have a
family there's no way
that you know dozens and dozens of
people i don't know how many people you
see or your wife sees you can take care
of their
be responsible for their health it's
just not gonna happen so that that will
never happen what is one way of
distracting yourself
are you cutting the cord if you don't if
you're not bombarded by those messages
but isn't it like a whack-a-mole like
you it pops up somewhere else in life
you know what i mean a lot of times okay
we're gonna get in deep and this is a
whole nother conversation but i'll leave
it very short
a lot of times you're going to something
to cover up some other pain it could be
psychological pain it could be physical
pain right
so
finding healthy alternatives to that
which doesn't sound too fun no this this
is a serious issue adverse childhood
experiences are one of the
difficult to prove because it's
difficult to quantify but they appear to
be a very large contributor are you
familiar with adverse childhood
experiences well i can i understand what
you're saying like you know traumatic
experiences kids have in their early
years and by traumatic we're talking
about things as major as sexual trauma
uh physical violence right they could
they could even be more benign
abandonment
uh abandonment yeah it is very extreme
correct absolutely but even more benign
things we're looking like a katrina i
mean maybe that's not benign but you're
displaced if we're looking at maybe
kovid not being in school not being
around kids being around parents that
are arguing because they don't have the
same income and they need to economic
burdens cause right they lost their
business and absolutely comes home these
things affect the brain and the
developing child in ways that are
not benign and this is well accepted in
the psychiatric literature is
unequivocal however benign they may
sound to us as adults for a child
they're very different and these
increase the risk of certain alcoholism
drug abuse but also heart disease lung
disease i mean the whole spectrum of
your health for the rest of your life is
colored when you experience an adverse
childhood experience and i gotta say i
don't remember the exact number right
now but it's in the order of at least 50
percent of the united states population
of adults have experienced
one childhood adverse experience it's an
unbelievably high number okay so you
can't go back and change that once you
grow up but so
but because you said earlier but you
were saying how
we have pains that we tried to cover up
yeah yeah yeah this is not it's not just
oxycodone pain we're talking about pain
pain is not only physical pain yeah
psychological yes and pain is in the
brain 100 because you don't need to be
pinched or to have a knife hit you
you people experience pain without
necessarily a noxious stimulus meaning
pain is 100 in the brain it's real but
it is in the brain because you can have
a painful experience i can some people
can get pulled to the knife and not feel
pain yeah pain is in the brain
so no matter what that's worse the pain
is we try to cover it up because we're
humans and
there is a cost one of my teachers went
to medical school said the body keeps
count
the body keeps going no matter how old
you were no matter what you're trying to
suppress the body does not forget you
can't out age it
you know it's not like okay i'm 10 years
older now it will go away
it does not go away until you deal with
it
and this is work so it is empowering to
recognize that you can
change
your relationship with that pain yeah
you may not be able to cure it when
patients have
terminal cancer they may not be able to
cure the pain yeah but they can address
it
and
when i have patients around the time of
surgery if
if they knew how powerful their
expectations in their brain were for
managing their post-operative pain it
would be a whole different ball game
pain is in the brain and you can change
your relationship with the pain and if
you just want one easy example yeah the
placebo effect
yeah yeah yeah you know so many of my
colleagues write off they say oh it was
quote just placebo okay just placebo i
ask you what does it mean to be just
placebo does that mean that you have a
treatment with no side effects that is
cheap because that sounds like a really
good deal to me
what more do you want
you know when we have the opposite we
call the nocebo effect
where instead of
the placebo we think of as conferring a
benefit the nocebo is conferring a
detriment classic example classic
example
when we're doing epidurals for women who
are laboring okay we first numb the skin
over the back when we're gonna do the
epidural
and so many of my colleagues used to say
ma'am you're gonna feel a little bee
sting a little bee sting this is a tiny
tiny needle to just inject a little bit
of lidocaine to numb up the skin so when
the bigger needle goes in it's not as
painful okay okay sometimes the doctor
or the nurse would say oh you're going
to feel a bee sting how do you think
that preps the nervous system right of
the patient who is in labor i mean for
goodness sakes place this woman's
delivering a baby they're already in
pain they are legitimately concerned if
not freaked out many times they're going
to feel the feasting peter i thought i
had to be sting i didn't like it all
right yeah what if you're allergic to
bee sticks
what's gonna happen oh my god so this is
this is the power of our thoughts and
the messages we are fed what would you
say
oh i have so many tricks i i don't even
i tell them to cough this is my when i'm
placing i place ivs every day for a
living right okay i tell i said cough do
you remember saying earlier distraction
what do the people do at the moment yeah
yeah yeah yeah you tell them to cough
you gotta concentrate on coughing and
patience almost nine out of ten if not
ten out of ten
the iv is in what what happened yeah
yeah
i can attest to that i'm i'm a baby with
needles it's just this
i'm at my weakest point when i see a
needle there there you go if you can
distract for a hot second yeah but then
we have messaging like this and we're
going a little off topic but what does
that mean does everyone was must wear a
face covering does that mean if you're
far from people if you're close to
people
oh you stay six feet apart okay got that
and i know this business required
it maybe it might be a little bit
unclear because it's a bit unclear i
find it arbitrary because if we're out
in the if we're out sitting in the field
this side
exercise and all the other positive
things that go with it everyone must
wear a face covering
so if you're following the rules
and like my wife for example she's
always gotten the a pluses she always
did well like this is hard for her my
wife is the same way right so you're so
are you supposed to you're throwing a
baseball with a friend and nobody's
around you do you need that yeah and if
you are not doing that are you doing
wrong and this is a big problem i think
we'll finish it on this one
is the messaging is very difficult that
that being from big corporations the
advertising
all the social media stuff we see
then going to dockers learning a little
bit about your perspective of it you
know you have to push a certain amount
of patience through you cannot look out
for my best interest spend hours of your
day worrying about that it's just
impossible it's insanity too to expect
that right you're not with a mask it's
okay we're we'll live
where you had your vaccines you had your
vag
yeah yeah yeah what are the low risk
high yield benefits we can do every day
okay remove our health yeah i mean masks
are great in the right setting but
they're addressing like a zero point
zero one percent what are the one
percent what are they ten percent
the fifty percent hitters that we can
control with our life to not have to be
on the or tape one day to not hopefully
need chemo we don't wanna see you you
don't yeah if i didn't have to see
another patient ever again i might lose
my job but i am happy for that if i
wasn't an md from stanford and harvard
who practiced acute care medicine no one
would listen to me right
but on both sides you have the big title
so people will well and if that's what
it takes to help
show people as close as we can get to
the truth about what the truth that
medicine is how much we have in our own
agency the possibility of changing our
health outcomes around yeah in ways that
aren't pushed out to the mainstream
well then if that's one step closer to
the truth let's do that
love it you got me fired up oh i'm ready
like where's the where do i march where
do i like
what do i run on what flag do i hold we
haven't even scratching the surface here
this is fired up yeah this is nothing
this content guys uh you know we're
touching many things
i really think anthony needs to start a
podcast he does have a youtube and
facebook channel
and a website a couple so i'm gonna
leave the links down below here let's
walk let's walk this last bit here uh
hope you got something out of that
i definitely did i feel healthier just
by being around your orbit put yourself
in the right environment and the body
will heal itself
i'm fired up you change enough days you
change a year you change enough years
you change a life
who's right guys whose life is worth
changing more than your own yeah in fact
and by doing so you bring those up
around you and you're a good inspiration
and role model we we all are role models
for everyone and that's why we need to
practice what we preach as a doctor
what would i be doing if i wasn't living
what i was saying okay i'm gonna get fit
starting today guys i'm gonna do better
and all all of your viewers out there
are gonna take this and it's gonna
imbibe in them yeah right right
great
thanks for watching anthony you're
awesome thank you all right until the
next one